movies they're magical take fifty Shades
of Grey for instance a film that I might
why are we starting with that could
shades of grey' sexy it's the sexy sex
film full sex the magic of cinema
Garrett yeah but nothing even
approaching the realm of possibility
happens in that do you think people
actually have sex contracts with one
another interesting question today we're
gonna find out come on No
[Music]
in Fifty Shades of Grey Christian Grey a
creepy playboy presents anastasia steele
a lady whose name is that with the
contract outlining the boundaries of the
potential BDSM relationship garrett i
just want to clarify that in no
circumstances would I ever want a
contract like that with you but we are
friends I would say so on the table in
front of you I've outlined the same
contract from the movie but with our
names in there
I see I'm the submissive yeah that's
fine
let's take a look at this because this
is pretty and net so
the fundamental purpose of this contract
is to allow the submissive to explore
her sensuality and his limits safely
good yeah this is all about me exactly
safe mm-hmm
let's get to part 9 the submissive is to
serve and obey the dominant in all
things Wow we just got right to it yes
but all things not just sex no not just
sex I would like you to make me a
spaghetti bolognese every weekend I've
never made a spaghetti bolognese before
I wanted to tastes exactly like my
grandmother's the dominant will ensure
all travel costs incurred by the
submissive that part is easy-peasy
I will get you uber pool right to my
apartment anywhere what do you take me
for I'm paying for it it's 239 the
submissive shall not touch or pleasure
himself sexually without permission from
the dominant okay permission not granted
by the way Oh 15.2 to the submissive
shall not look directly into the eyes is
the dominant except when specifically
instructed to do so
now why is your shop Garrett look down I
haven't signed it yet I'm willing to
sign it you'll sign some modifications
for instance appendix three is
swallowing semen acceptable to the
submissive where we're gonna get that so
we'll just we'll just say no if you
could pencil that one in there so but
the rest of this stuff is bondage
acceptable to the submissive hands in
front sure hands behind back why not
ankles got him please also elbows sure
tied of furniture sure blindfolding yeah
gagging whoa genital clamps what are
they clapping on to the genitals if we
had a clamp right now I think I could
clamp some things under the genitals
all right let's cross that one out if
we're gonna do this I just want
everything to be aboveboard all right I
wanna cross our T's dot our eyes we
should see a real lawyer okay go
[Music]
thanks for helping us out yeah no I'm
happy to sit down with you guys see if
we can help you out with your legal
needs today you have any experience with
contracts of a sexual nature we did
represent a client she was a adult film
star known for her very large natural
breasts we've also done some work for
one client who was actually making
devices that attached and nipples or
whatever else in an electrical shock
it's not an area that I necessarily
advertise as my specialty but have you
seen Fifty Shades of Grey I did watch it
recently yeah what do you think
I thought the acting was okay I guess
that that's right yeah what area of law
would this fall under at its core it is
contract law prostitution could possibly
come up and it's seemingly only legal in
Nevada theoretically let's say in Nevada
this would be enforceable okay and I
were to make eye contact with her mm-hmm
I'm not going to do now
try that idea can she sue me she could
possibly get a court order that says you
do you need to avoid eye contact with
her and if that court if I break that
I'd go to prison that's completely
enforceable contempt of court could
allow for you to be arrested in certain
scenarios if you continue to violate the
injunction oh my goodness
trying to find some things that would be
hard to enforce like the submissive
shall not touch her pleasure himself
sexually without the permission from the
dominant right that's probably that
one's kind of interesting because that's
that's actually a contract where you've
agreed not to engage in sex so that
portion possibly could be enforceable
[Music]
haha was not expecting that okay so the
dominant may flog spank whip or
corporally punish the submissive as she
sees fit that seems like that would
maybe cross the line potentially if I
don't if I can just hurt you so I'm
gonna say that some part of that is
gonna be enforceable which parts you can
contract for what's called assumption of
the risk baseball games you if you look
on the back ticket you waive the right
to sue them if you get hit by a baseball
oh yeah
is it ever for purpose of discipline if
you wanted just a contract so that you
would come whip you once a week you
could probably contract it as long as
it's not sexual in nature so I've got a
better chance of having a legally
enforceable contract if Jen comes and
beats the [ __ ] out of me as opposed to
we have sex yes sure overall movie Fifty
Shades of Grey right this contract are
you saying it is enforceable or is not
enforceable
it's most likely not enforceable for a
number of reasons the content of what
they're contracting to do is going to be
prohibitive under probably a lot of
walls
so contractually fifty shades of gray
total load of horse hockey
but if you believe in the magic of
cinema you know go in with eyes wide
open and don't look them in the face
magic of cinema
on to the next adventure come on
it's two-hour drive back to the office I
wanted to know
[Music]